the one piece
a treasure of value so unimaginable that
countless pirates have fought and died
trying to find it for decades
and despite the series having continued
for over 20 years now
the story of one piece has yet to shed
light on what it truly is
what this appraised treasure is our only
solace lying in small hints dispersed
throughout the story
and we will only truly know its identity
i'm sure once we reach the end of the
story
in a series that is notorious for having
no end in sight
on the grand line which circumvents the
one-piece world with no defined
beginning or
end as an infinite loop and ring the
single defined end of this journey
the point we can definitively look
forward to is the one piece
but when thinking about what the one
piece is theorizing on the endless
possibilities
based on historical thinking and
philosophy there is no
imaginable way that we can settle on its
identity until the moment we see it with
our own eyes
the one piece is not real until luffy
and the audience witnesses it themselves
until then it simply consists of a
collective of theories of fans and
characters
which amalgamate together to form this
idolized and magnificent
abstract thought that is the one piece
[Music]
the theories about what the one piece
will be arise from the vast
amount of people from different
backgrounds who often make the one piece
into what they want it to be
not what it necessarily will be
as a series that has surpassed limits
and astounded its readers time and time
again
our expectations are constantly raised
and becoming high
and thus the one piece is becoming this
grand ending that
fans want it to be despite not knowing
what it actually will be
so why am i discussing this the
philosophy behind
the unexpected what it means to
anticipate the unknown
is there any problem with there being
theories and high expectations for a
series that can
probably meet those expectations well
before answering this let me explain the
expression of
turtles all the way down
stephen hawking's book a brief history
of time explains this theory quite well
through an anecdote
a well-known scientist once gave a
public lecture on astronomy
he described how the earth orbits around
the sun and how the sun
in turn orbits around the center of a
vast collection of stars called our
galaxy
and at the end of the lecture a little
old lady at the back of the room got up
and said
what you have told us is rubbish the
world is really a flat plate supported
on the back of a giant tortoise
the scientist gave a superior smile
before replying
what is the tortoise standing on you're
very clever young man very clever said
the old lady
but it's turtles all the way down
the idea of turtles all the way down
restates that what we know today
what is thought to be scientific fact or
simply truth
just consists of theories setting upon
endless other
proven and justified theories it is what
we call
infinite regress that one specific
proposition can be
infinitely questioned because it is
based on an endless series of ideas
built upon each other
but it warns of a dangerous possibility
it is very plausible that with these
many theories we are sitting on
disproving one can collapse the tower
itself and our very belief system
just like copernicus determined that the
sun was in fact in the middle of the
solar system
and that earth revolved around it not
the other way around he completely
disproved the widely accepted way of
thinking across all of europe
we used to think the one piece was
simply the collection of rogers
treasures he found and accumulated on
his journey through the grand line
until it was revealed that the treasure
belonged to joyboy
long before roger as one piece continues
we are constantly finding new hints
towards the identity of the one piece
that both disprove many existing
theories and give rise to new ones
it essentially proves that our very
fragile knowledge
of what the one piece is can be toppled
over
very easily
throughout pre-time skip one piece
though there were many theories pointing
to what the one piece could be
the one fear among both fans and
characters within the series
was the very possible outcome that it
didn't exist
at all that luffy and the world were
simply relying on a dead man's words
until whitebeard said one sentence in
marineford that toppled these theories
and gave rise to the truth
one piece
the idea of one piece is so magnificent
and idealistic that
should it actually be real it is
certainly
enough justification to keep going and
fight on to reach that end goal
knowing that it doesn't exist removes
that persuasion
that justification for our efforts
knowing that the goal does not in fact
exist when meeting rayleigh and sabaodi
luffy refused to hear what the one piece
was from the willing rayleigh
because there would be no merit in
becoming the pirate king
to this journey to the top if he knew
what the one piece was and the ending
was
before even getting there in a story
with seemingly no end
in sight in the grand line a section of
the ocean with no defined end
they need the one piece to keep them
anchored
the journey is not easy fate is
merciless at times
but it is the one piece that defines the
end the finish line for both the
characters and the fans
if the one piece did not exist the
entire series itself would lose its
impact
and anticipation but
this quote also invokes a separate but
equally terrifying outcome
what if that persuasive goal is in fact
just the journey that it brought us on
this is a famous quote or rather
notorious as it is usually revered for
just how cheesy it is
just as much as if the one piece never
existed to begin with
if the one piece were just a reflection
of the friends you made along the way
the series power would once again
collapse
which points us to the importance of the
one piece
as the countless collections of
expectations among fans of different
beliefs
that form an unknown yet revered goal to
end
all goals it points us to the importance
of the identity of the one piece
as it is the paramount factor in
creating a good end for the series with
no
end
i'm sure many would be satisfied with
one piece continuing on forever
for many of us there's never been a part
of our lives when one piece wasn't
serialized when it wasn't airing
luffy and his crew continue to battle
their way to the top while getting
endlessly closer to the one piece but
never reaching it
like achilles and the tortoise the
series is purposely made to
make the grand line seem endless like
there's no end in sight
but we will at some point have to end
one piece
to find the treasure and cap this
journey and oda understands this
in an interview he clarified that the
one piece is not something like the
growth your heart went through something
cheesy like the journey is the
destination
after the adventure like this one where
luffy's resources were constantly
exhausted
where fate was merciless it is only fair
to give an
actual reward again the ease that this
confirmation gives fans the relief in
knowing that it is an actual treasure
once again reminds us that we need a
good ending to the series that we all
want it that the one piece must be that
but of course just like the grand line
itself this circles
all the way back to the beginning of the
video and the idea that the expectations
of what the one piece is very
significantly
to only have a single reward to actually
define what the one piece is
after all this time topples the
countless columns of turtles all the way
down that believe
anything otherwise just as proving it
was real and marine ford cut down the
amount of theories to
only those that believed the one piece
did exist
and just as oda saying that it is an
actual treasure removes any theories
believing that the one piece was an
intangible reflection of the journey
itself
it slims down the endless possibilities
except this time the ending will cut all
of these columns down
and leave only one it will create
one single theory that is actually fact
and it will surely bring dissatisfaction
to some by disproving them
it is inevitable so to answer the
question i posed earlier of whether this
is
inherently a problem it is and it isn't
sure it'll collapse thousands of
theories and will not be able to meet
the various
expectations set across the world
but it brings the end that the series
needs regardless
just as the human race fantasizes about
aliens living in space
the advanced technology they may bring
the supermen they might become
just to realize that maybe
extraterrestrial life is simply a
microorganism
incapable of even thought just as we
believe luffy is the key to finding the
one piece or joy boy or the straw hat or
momo
the possibilities and reasoning are
endless but once the result comes the
theories topple
into one factual result that
is the inherent philosophy of the
anticipated unknown
and of the one piece
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga
and character analyses
you